we scrimmage USA at that summer before
the Olympics about three to four times
and the one thing that Larry Brown that
was the coach for that team so they
asked us to play you know man-to-man
throughout the whole scrimmages that we
had so our coaching staff was like we're
gonna play his own the whole game
so we had an advantage as far as
preparation when it came down to playing
USA but it was an amazing moment for
Puerto Rico basketball for the history
of basketball in our Island to this day
they celebrate that day like it's a
birthday it was a team effort everybody
obviously did their part for us to be
able to accomplish what we did and we in
the history books man I'm truly honored
and blessed to be a part of that moment
we played with a lot of respect a lot of
dignity because I you know the fan base
that we have in Puerto Rico is not only
in the island it's all around the world
Puerto Ricans they come out everywhere
you know yeah and we got cousins and
grandparents and you know Brothers
everywhere so it's truly an honor to to
just represent the island the way we do